bonjour et bienvenue pour cette absence
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la curiosité
de loriol près de minerve dans le sud de
la france un lieu plus connu sous le nom
de la monte et qui descend
comment vérifier qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une légende quand on n'a pas de
matériel scientifique et quand comme
nous il ne vous reste que les reliefs du
pique nique de ce midi faisons un peu de
méthode scientifique commençons d'abord
par mettre en évidence le phénomène ont
tout va bien réelle va dans la descente
dans l'autre sens la descente c'est par
là
qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est moi qu'elle veut c'est moi qu'elle
veut on a bourg recommencer des dizaines
de fois rien n'est fait la bouteille
refusent de descendre et persiste à
remonter la pente
c'est un vrai mystère comment expliquer
un phénomène aussi bizarre tâchons
maintenant de proposer des hypothèses
rationnels pour expliquer ce phénomène
l'une des hypothèses proposées et cachan
magnétique interférerait avec la gravité
terrestre
pour tester cette hypothèse rien de plus
simple il suffit de prendre la boîte de
conserve très sensible aux champs
électromagnétiques et de voir si elle va
plus vite que la bouteille d'eau dans la
descente ou dans la montée enfin un truc
comme ça quoi 2
donc le champ magnétique c'est du pipeau
deuxième hypothèse il ne s'agirait que
d'une illusion d'optique et dans ce cas
tout ne serait qu'une affaire de point
de vue et oui il suffit de prendre un
peu de hauteur pour se rendre compte que
ce qui avait l'air d'être le bas de la
pente est en fait la partie la plus
élevée de la route
ce faux plat donne l'impression de
monter à cause de la présence de se
lasser de route en contrebas qui
serpente dans la montagne
bref pour faire de la science vous
n'avez pas besoin de matériel de pointe
ni de super calculateur il vous suffit
simplement d'un peu de pensée
rationnelle et de méthodes scientifiques
en gros tout ce qu'il vous faut pour
faire de la science se trouve là dans
votre tête